pasamos a nuestra revista de prensa en
directo América y con los buenos días
para usted Marta cómo está Hola Ángela
Buenos días Todo bien gracias pero vamos
a empezar esta revista de prensa con los
reportes de los medios rusos y
ucranianos sobre lo ocurrido en las
últimas horas en belgorot y que ha
estado en el top de las noticias
internacionales vamos a empezar Marta
con el medio ucraniano kiev post pues y
Ángela vamos a empezar con el que hace
una suerte de explainer sobre los
últimos acontecimientos en esta región
rusa fronteriza con Ucrania del gorot
que ha suscitado muchas confusiones en
las últimas horas ayer hubo lo que se
supone que es y porque lo han
reivindicado así dos grupos de incursión
anti Putin concretamente los cuerpos de
voluntarios rusos y la legión de la
libertad de Rusia
encursionaron en la región de velgorot
porque quieren liberar Dicen esta región
de las tropas rusas y combatir lo que
dicen es el régimen dictatorial de
Vladimir Putin cruzaron la frontera
reportes con dos tanques un vehículo
blindado de transporte personal y otros
nueve vehículos blindados según bloguero
rusos en el terreno y que participan en
la guerra en Ucrania el gobernado y el
gobernador local de vélgorot fueron
atacados tanto las sedes del Ministerio
del interior de la región de vélgorot
como los servicios de inteligencia todos
estos ataques han dejado varios muertos
y heridos el kremlin ha culpado
directamente aquí de lo sucedido y ha
declarado una alerta antiterrorista que
dota de poderes especiales a las fuerzas
de seguridad que pueden intervenir tanto
las comunicaciones como restringir la
movilidad además dice el kremlin que
esto Solo es una maniobra de distracción
de las fuerzas de kiev tras la toma de
bahamut por parte del grupo Wagner quien
niega cualquier tipo de participación en
lo ocurrido pero sí que aprovecha toda
esta situación para hacer propaganda y
pues decirle a esa población fronteriza
que las tropas rusas son el enemigo y
que precisamente era eso lo que Rusia
dice que quería evitar con esta llamada
operación especial en Ucrania Marta el
medio independiente ruso medusa también
reporta sobre este hecho en el que en
realidad hay mucha más confusión que
respuestas No pues así es Ángela el
medusa Comenta tanto las declaraciones
del gobernador
y a cheslab glat que dice que todos los
últimos ataques en la región dejaron una
un balance de ocho heridos y varias
personas muertas y también recoge las
declaraciones del principal asesor del
presidente ucraniano Vladimir zelemsky
mijailo podoliac que publicó un tweet en
las últimas horas diciendo el único
poder político real en un estado
totalitario hermético inhabilitado
inevitablemente recaerá en los
movimientos partisanos armados bueno
Marta en la prensa rusa aliada del
kremlin también por supuesto están
haciendo sus conjeturas y tenemos que
darle equilibrio a esta noticia no lo
hemos intentado en nuestros informativos
y acá pues como no por supuesto y hemos
destacado un artículo del cónsumos calla
Prada un medio muy afín al kremlin que
se pregunta textualmente por qué los
terroristas ucranianos hicieron esta
incursión en la región de vélgorot
además dice que todo esto sería parte de
un grupo ruso de Sabotaje y
reconocimiento que forma parte o que
está participando en la Guerra de
Ucrania de parte del lado de las tropas
de kiev este artículo del Consejo skaya
Prada atribuye todo esto a un plan de
bolodimir zelemski que dice que prioriza
la mediatización de sus batallas por
tener los titulares de su lado y que no
valora la vida de sus militares dice que
después de mariu Paul de severoniesk o
de bahamut ahora celensky quería revivir
esta dinámica y revivir estos titulares
a su favor incursionando en la región de
belgorot y dice este artículo del
Consejo es que haya Prada el componente
mediático
prevalecerá sobre la realidad lo que
confirma la falta de oportunidad para
entablar negociaciones que solo
conducirán a sus rendición eso dice este
medio muy al final kremlin lo que uno se
pregunta es sea uno responsabilidad de
quién Por qué sorprende tanto que une
incursión de estas tenga lugar y sabe
que hablaba jefferen y pregosín en estas
alocuciones pues tan polémicas que daba
diciendo que Rusia no defiende bien sus
fronteras y que esto va a cambiar
completamente pues las denominaciones en
cuanto a lo que es la guerra sí
no tiene la legitimidad para hacerlo
porque no es el ministro de defensa ruso
Pero bueno también hemos destacado
Ángela el medio también ruso un poquito
más Imparcial que el consumo Es que haya
Prada que sostiene que el comité de
investigación ruso ha abierto una
investigación por un caso penal bajo
seis preceptos que implican delitos de
acto terrorista usurpación de la vida de
los agentes del orden intento asesinato
destrucción intencional daño a la
propiedad y circulación de armas y
explosivos además sostiene este artículo
que
ya estaba en su nivel más alto desde
octubre del año pasado cuando Putin la
decretó no solo en esta región sino en
siete más fronterizas con Ucrania Bueno
vamos a cambiar un poco de tema pero
vamos a continuar en los terrenos de
Ucrania alrededor de la Guerra el medio
estadounidense de New York Times ha
publicado unas imágenes Pues que son
espectaculares por nombrar algún
adjetivo sobre la destrucción de la
ciudad de qué nos tiene Marta pues
Angela esto es un reportaje y bueno unas
imágenes de un fotógrafo de New York
Times empotrado con las tropas
ucranianas que tuvo acceso a grabar
estas imágenes con dron el pasado
viernes como ustedes podrán estar viendo
en las imágenes detrás de mí se ve a una
ciudad de bahamut totalmente destruida y
que ha estado en disputa entre 9 y 10
meses aunque quiera asegura que todavía
sigue todavía en los alrededores en
disputa las imágenes se ven en la
destrucción de la urbe edificios
quemados escuelas destruidas y parques
totalmente llenos de cráteres dice el
near Times la noción de un ganador sin
embargo desafía lo que están tan
claramente perdido muchas vidas y
hogares en la ciudad que alguna vez fue
pacífica conocida por sus minas de sal
vino espumoso y ahora en gran parte
reducida a cenizas
bien Marta vamos a terminar hoy con los
reportes que hacen también los medios
españoles sé que en sus artículos y
editoriales hablan sobre un caso de
racismo muy muy sonado Durante los
últimos días contra el jugador brasileño
vinicios Junior y es que estos medios
denuncian entre otras cosas Marta la
falta de acción por parte de las
autoridades competentes lo cual tengo
que decirle no es ninguna sorpresa no es
ninguna novedad Ángela vamos a empezar
con el periódico El mundo que dice que
la liga española no toma las medidas
suficientes para atajar esta lacra que
mientras Inglaterra potencia la vía
penal para combatir el racismo o Italia
también persigue cada vez más estas
prácticas en España no está sucediendo
nada de esto la ley que da potestad al
árbitro para actuar contra estas la
contra esta lacra es la ley de 2007 que
dice ley contra la violencia el racismo
la xenofobia y la intolerancia en el
deporte sin embargo los árbitros al
final pues tienen una gran
responsabilidad que no asumen en muchas
ocasiones solo emplazado un partido en
2019 Y todo porque se acusaba un jugador
de nazismo y esto lo denunció la afición
contraria y al final los jugadores se
negaron a jugar la segunda parte O sea
que ni siquiera fue el árbitro quien
tomó la decisión lo que evidencia pues
la pobreza de esta ley y todos los
grises Pues que acompañan y permiten que
esto siga sucediendo mire muy
rápidamente el país y la vanguardia
también se pronuncian sobre este tema Si
anhelamos destacado dos editoriales
tanto del país como de la vanguardia por
ejemplo el país dice que deben ser las
autoridades del fútbol quién lideren las
bueno las prácticas contra el racismo
que lideren esa erradicación porque si
no pueden contaminar las competiciones
infantiles y juveniles y por otra parte
la vanguardia dice que el caso de
vinícidos tiene que evidenciar y poner
de relieve esta lacra en todos los
estamentos del fútbol textualmente una
lucha en la que no pueden bajarse los
brazos y menos en el fútbol por el
efecto amplificador que Acompaña a este
deporte un caso vergonzoso y que
esperamos que realmente puedan verse
acciones alrededor de él Muchísimas
gracias a usted y nos vemos mañana
Gracias Aunque hasta